If you master the mind-reading technique of reading words with the movement of the edge,
you should be able to have a conversation regardless of the size
.
Mokunenji Hama no
Koide 6 consecutive hours
[music]
That's
why
I've mastered mind-reading.
If there is, I
want to buy a memo for a scrap of notebook I want to throw it
[music]
Buber,
get drunk
[music]
Get
me, when I was close to you the other day, I could hear it cheaply Because it was
close, it's
not bone conduction Okay
, mother Len, it's bone conduction  Let's go with that next time
Princess siro
Good morning Good morning
Textbooks are good
I
'm no good I've got ringing in my ears instead of my voice
I won't give up
that mountain